c'est un projet vieux de plus de 40 ans
le pont d'Acher porté par le Département
des ivelines est prévu pour 2027 il doit
relier la route départemental 190 à
Triel sursène et la RD30 AHR le tronçon
se composera d'un deux fois de voix
établissant également une liaison entre
la 13 et la 15 et un pont de 800 m
enjambant la scène c'est c'est l'un des
objectifs et l'objectif principal c'est
de désenclaver la boucle de Chantelou et
effectivement le le deuxième sujet c'est
qu'on va permettre comme ça de désaturer
la ville de poissie et de permettre
demain au utilisateurs des transports en
commun qui vont venir prendre le RER ou
le tram T13 à poissie d'accéder plus
facilement qu'aujourd'hui quand on fait
des projets d'infrastructure euh il y a
toujours des des gens qui sont gênés
parce qu'en proximité de l'ouvrage mais
il y a beaucoup plus de gens qui vont
bénéficier de cet ouvrage et donc le
politique il est là pour prendre en
compte l'intérêt général coût du projet
200 millions d'euros une phase
préparatoire et des travaux de
déboisement ont d'ors et déjà commencé
mais ce projet est loin de faire
l'unanimité une marche était est
organisé ce dimanche 12 novembre pour
dénoncer le projet routier pour la
plupart le pont d'Acher est un problème
pour l'environnement avec ces 40000
véhicules par jour la pollution pour
tout le territoire notamment via les
vents qui viennent de l'Ouest sur les
villes d'andrésie et
d'Acher c'est 14 % de plus d'émissions
de gaz effet de serre avec ce projet par
rapport à une situation sans projet
c'est la biodiversité qui est attaquée
parce que il y a plus de 50 espèces
protégées sur sur le tracé sur le
territoire alors que l'arrêté
préfectoral n'a autorisé que la
destruction que de 30 espèces protégées
pour l'heure un référé suspension et un
recours contentieux ont été déposés le
tribunal de Versailles devrait les
examiner dans les prochains jours